i just told my homie the other day bro
like one of my young homies like bro
you're not
bro you're not going to be special or do
anything different or
you're not going to be
who you want to be
doing the same [ __ ] that been going on
in the hood for the last 50 years you
know what i'm saying like bro we got
homies from since 60s 70s that kill
[ __ ] and do the crazy [ __ ] and go to
jail forever like what makes you think
that you're gonna stand out and be
special doing the same exact [ __ ] and we
know the outcome bro yeah you already
seen this movie play out there's people
who did this for you just to show you
like yeah yeah bro it's decades of
seeing it though bro we got hundreds of
homies
maybe a thousand homies in jail with
life and like they wish they wouldn't
did this [ __ ] so it's like
bro and that's why
that's why my transition into this [ __ ]
like sometimes it's difficult but when i
look at that it's like all right i could
be doing this and be stuck in and out of
prison who wants to do that who gives a
[ __ ] about that you know what i'm saying
it's like all right do something
different what can i bring different to
the hood so my presence is
bringing that different [ __ ] and making
it cool like all right let's do music um
let's do clothes do all right you uh
water you don't wrap or yeah water you
know rap all right um
you don't even want to be in the
entertainment [ __ ] okay it's real estate
it's other business [ __ ] like and it's
fine you still a homie you still cool
like [ __ ] what [ __ ] talking about you
know what i'm saying